as you approach Harrison in Arkansas
there's obvious signs of a very public
battle with racism a former Confederate
States its grappling with a problematic
present trying to escape the shadows of
America's oldest hate group in nearby
zinc is the headquarters of the Knights
of the Ku Klux Klan I'm here to meet
Thomas Robb the National Director he's
unroped unsuited well this here is our
our office and we do clerical work here
membership applications and reports and
then of course we reproduce DVDs here
and so on it's a family enterprise for
Thomas and his daughter Rachel and you
in and it this is you yeah do you still
take part in public parades well we hold
a parade I guess you taught in Pulaski
Tennessee each year the Klan has
declined significantly it's fractured
but there is a new era of tension are
you worried about the future now that
there will be more violence I think
there will definitely be more violence I
think whatever whatever it politicians
or a preacher
newscaster only wants to condemn the
white nationalist of Charlottesville but
doesn't want to equally condemn at least
at least equally condemn the antiphon
and the black lives matter and the
anti-white demonstrators it involves
them they're desecrating their
cemeteries they're one taking down
monuments of our heroes they want to
urinate on ours the symbols of our faith
and we're supposed to just accept it and
if we offer it it's just a whimper of
protest
we're considered haters and Biggers and
monsters and Nazis there's nothing about
your message that's mainstream is that
well look at who those who vote for
Donald Trump in 2016 I think my message
is mainstream we don't promote hatred of
anybody we think everybody has right to
love that heritage and culture
or we're concerned with the how come
when white people said I love my people
I love my heritage they want to call
that a racial hatred the clans official
newspaper endorse Donald Trump but he
clearly disavowed the group and said he
didn't want to energize them in the
1920s it had as many as four million
members now it's estimated there are
thousands many at war with each other
just because people are talking about
the Klan doesn't make them powerful
I never said partly I don't say I think
about being powerful
we're not powerful and I didn't know
illusions being powerful if the fact is
we have a voice people respond to it
whether that voice whether people join
the Klan if you can come involved in the
white nationalist movement I don't care
I'm not trying to make the Klan the
biggest club if you want to use that
phrase in the country how do you feel
about African Americans I think they
have a right to be African Americans the
same way I have a right to be white okay
people I think a people's abomination
Hispanics same as black the same answer
he markets his group as Christian
rebranding the clan as the first
alt-right organization he tries to make
white supremacy sound almost normal
Yeti also seems comfortable being
confined to his own isolated enclaves
for 15 years a group of local people
have been fighting to make clear their
city is not a haven for racists when you
know you hear that the head of the Klan
has moved into the area he uses Harrison
as that geographic location to help
people find him then you know it paints
an image that just isn't true so we're
working together to counter that we're
trying to get the word out that hey okay
so he gets his mail here that's about it
that's the the most significant impact
this man has on this community and I'm
speaking from a black man living here
who with his family has been happy and
successful and and and productive and
whites now or joining hands or with the
black and a little and other people to
say they now hate so once you get that
started word of the Klan have to go
where can they go when people ask me
well you know why are you on the task
force you're not going to be able to
solve this problem I said well you know
we probably aren't going to be able to
completely solve this problem if I want
to have conversations about race and and
how people are feeling this is the best
place to come and to have those
conversations and to make cross-cultural
friends
[Music]
they have hope and faith in their
message but they haven't won the battle
yet and the rest of the country is just
joining it bode violent Sky News
Harrison Arkansas